-Performing "Headstone"
from their Grammy-nominated
album "Skeletons,"
please welcome Brothers Osborne!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Hey!
-♪ My skin ain't thin,
but when I come unhinged ♪
♪ I'm a little
bit more than crazy ♪
♪ Work like a dog,
but the way I talk ♪
♪ Is a little laid back
and lazy ♪
♪ I'm not a man of many words ♪
♪ But my words
are as good as gold ♪
♪ And you can bet your ass
I'll have your back ♪
♪ When the rubber
meets the road ♪
♪♪
-♪ Write that on my headstone ♪
♪ Write that on my headstone ♪
♪♪
♪ Off the rails, off the walls ♪
♪ Never was the one
to back down ♪
♪ Gave it hell
and I had a ball ♪
♪ Like tomorrow
was never coming back 'round ♪
-♪ Live to love
and love to live ♪
♪ Like the lights
are never coming back on ♪
♪ Day and night, night and day ♪
♪ I did it my way,
right or wrong ♪
♪ It's a wonder
that I made it this long ♪
-♪ Write that on my headstone ♪
♪♪
♪ Write that on my headstone ♪
♪ Yeah, when I'm dead and gone ♪
♪♪
♪ Write that on my headstone ♪
-♪ Yes ♪
♪♪
♪ Here lies a man
who gave a damn ♪
♪ Wasn't scared
to stand for something ♪
♪ Lived it hard and fast
in that dash ♪
♪ Carved between those numbers ♪
♪ And if you're reading this
you can reminisce ♪
♪ But don't cry for me,
brother ♪
♪ Pour enough whiskey
on this grave ♪
♪ To make it all the way
down six feet under ♪
-♪ Write that on my headstone ♪
♪♪
♪ Write that on my headstone ♪
♪ Yeah, when I'm dead and gone ♪
♪♪
♪ Write that on my headstone ♪
♪ Headstone ♪
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]